I am in the middle of a huge dilemma, I really
don’t like jellyfish, they freak me out,
but I love lasers… they’re so cool!
And this new science is making lasers with
jellyfish!?
AHHH!!
Hey photonic reflectors, Trace here for DNews.
When lasers were first invented, they were
called “a solution looking for a problem.”
In the decades since then, we’ve found a
number of ways to make lasers useful.
Barcode scanners, industrial cutting, surgeries,
pointing at things... you name it!
Now, physicists and bioengineers are collaborating
to help us make new, even more specialized
lasers… thanks to proteins from jellyfish.
But first... lasers were theorized in 1917
in a paper by Einstein, and first accomplished
in 1960 by T.H.
Maiman.
LASER is an acronym for Light Amplification
by Stimulated Emission of Radiation.
Lasers make light, but not like regular light
bulbs.
In a regular lightbulb, electrons are pushed
through a filament, causing them to get excited.
That excitement causes them to throw little
photons of light and heat energy every which
way!
It’s chaos!
Lasers are far more precise…
A laser takes the same principle of emitting
light, but instead of going every which way,
it’s an organized, tightly packed, beam
of photons.
This organization requires specific substances
to emit their photons in a specific way so
the photons are monochromatic, coherent and
directional!
Put simply, a lightbulb is a running herd
of people, but a laser is a marching army.
Different substances produce different wavelengths
of light, and different types of lasers are
good for different things.
Red laser light can be used in sensors, spectrometers
and CD-players and can be made by exciting
a helium-neon gas or garnet.
Blue or violet lasers can be used for data
storage applications (it’s what’s in a
blu-ray player) and in medical and and are
made by exciting gallium nitride…
But I digress.
One of the most advanced laser types yet invented
is a polariton laser.
It’s created by exciting the atoms of a
supercooled Bose-Einstein condensate (a crazy
state of matter) to create half-matter, half-light
quasiparticles...
Yeah.
It’s pretty insane science, and not the
easiest thing to do.
These polariton lasers can be used in quantum
physics, to tag cancer cells, or to make data
transfers faster, but they’re so hard to
make!
Supercooling ain’t easy!
Which brings us back to jellyfish (shudder).
In 2011, scientists pulsed low energy light
onto lab-grown cells containing a green fluorescent
protein (GFP) from the Aequorea victoria jellyfish.
By putting them into a mirrored chamber, the
cells created an organized beam of monochromatic
photons!
Green laser light!
These were the first biological lasers!
Now in this new 2016 study, the researchers
took that GFP and grew it on a bed of e.coli
bacteria -- creating enhanced GFP (eGFP) that
glows way brighter.
// enhance *air typing* // they created a
500 nanometer-thin film of this eGFP, placed
it into a mirrored housing… pulsed it with
light… aaaaand!
VOILA!!
A polariton laser for quantum applications
at room temperature!
No supercooling required!
Easy!
See, the reason they needed supercooled lasers
in the first place was to keep the photons
from moving around too much -- super-cold
particles behave better.
But, the jellyfish proteins are barrel-shaped,
causing the photons to align perfectly.
It only makes green light, but the hunt is
on for more glowing proteins… coral have
one that glows red…
From jellyfish, to lasers, to bioengineering
to quantum physics.
I’m jelly.
That’s super cool.
We can’t do DNews episodes without our sponsors.
Thanks to Graze for sponsoring this epsiodes.
Graze makes snacking exciting by combining
wholesome ingredients with flavors we all
love to create over 100 nutritionist-approved
snacks.
Go to graze.com and enter promo code DNEWS
to get a free, sampler box delivered to your
home or work.
Of course, this new study is predicated on
the fact that the jellyfish had glowing cells
in the first place!
If you’re wondering why some animals glow,
go watch this video.
And tell us in the comments if this science
blew your mind a little bit, because it did
mine and please subscribe for more mindblowing
science.